Müssen wir die erde verlassen die ressourcen werden knapper der klimawandel setzt der erde zur überbevölkerung umweltverschmutzung
Stephen hawking sagt ja wir müssen weg aber wohin wunschthema bei whatsapp
Terraforming wie können fremde planeten für uns menschen bewohner gemacht werden der mars beispielsweise als eine zweite erde und das innerhalb weniger
Jahrhunderte wie das gehen soll und wie realistisch das wirklich ist jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der mars ist tatsächlich ein planet auf dem leben zumindest theoretisch vorstellbar ist und das aus verschiedenen gründen beispielsweise
Hat er zumindest eine dünne atmosphäre die vor kosmischer strahlung schützt zum anderen sind dort die temperaturen
Hinnehmbar und es gibt genug sonnenlicht das man nutzen könnte zudem ist der tag nacht rhythmus
Auf dem mars dem der erde sehr ähnlich ein tag auf diesem planeten dauert 24 stunden 39 minuten und 35 sekunden
natürlich können menschen nicht einfach
so ohne technische hilfsmittel jahren umziehen aber
Im vergleich zur venus ist der mars ein paradies das sagen zumindest die verantwortlichen
des projektes mars rang die schon in naher zukunft
Menschen für immer auf dem mars siedeln lassen wollen wir hatten ja darüber berichtet doch fest steht auch ohne
technische hilfsmittel ist sein leben auf dem mars unvorstellbar das stichwort der science-fiction-literatur
Terraforming um den böden trocknen maß quasi in eine
Zweite erde zu verwandeln es gab zeiten in denen der mars wohl warm war
Und tatsächlich auch flüssiges wasser auf seiner oberfläche hat doch seine atmosphäre und das wasser sind vor etwa
3,8 bis 3,5 milliarden jahren
verschwundene zum einen liegt das an seiner geringen masse zum anderen fehlen ihm ein heißer kern und ein
Magnetfeld das ihn schützen könnte und so ist der mars
ausgekühlt denn der sonnenwind konnte ihn ungehindert
Angreifen und ihm seine atmosphäre nehmen das wasser verdunstet, zum teil der andere teil versickerte wurde in tiefere schichten
Und um den mars wieder lebens freundlicher zu machen bräuchte er eine
Dichtere atmosphäre die sich atmen lässt die temperatur auf seiner oberfläche würde sich dann erhöhen und wasser
könnte in flüssiger form
existieren
unabdingbar für leben auf dem mars zudem würde der angesammelte wasser dampf in der atmosphäre für einen
treibhauseffekt sorgen so dass sich die temperatur weiter erhöht klingt alles ziemlich
Easy ist es aber in der realität dann doch nicht oder etwa. Wohl es gibt verschiedene ideen
Mikroorganismen könnten mit, ihrem stoffwechsel die atmosphäre des mars für uns optimieren man könnte das eis durch gezielte
asteroiden bombardements schmelzen lassen oder aber mit spiegeln in seiner umlaufbahn
seine oberfläche aufheizen aber es gibt nicht nur kurios klingen die vision sondern tatsächlich auch wissenschaftliche studien dazu der fachbegriff
4eco
jesus, der knackpunkt ist wohl tatsächlich in erster linie die erwärmung des planeten
1984 schlug der physiker james lovelock
Treibhausgase in die atmosphäre zu bringen vor so genannte perfluorcarbon pfc
hunderte produktionsanlagen so große autos ließen dann die mars
oberflächentemperatur innerhalb von 100 jahren um 20 grad steigen love rocks berechnungen von minus 60 grad auf
Minus 40 grad celsius das co2 aus den polen würde in die atmosphäre über gilt als treibhausgas würde es für eine weitere
temperatursteigerung song auf etwa plus 20 grad celsius innerhalb von
600 jahren ja schnell geht das wirklich nicht das wassereis würde sich verflüssigen was die bildung von mehreren und seen zur folge hätte
Durch einen hohen atmosphärendruck würde die verdunstung verhindert werden innerhalb einiger jahrhunderte während der mars also warm und feucht
Relativ perfekte lebensbedingungen nötig wäre dann noch für uns menschen ein
sauerstoff atmen system etwa sowie taucher sie nutzen doch paszek da wäre es natürlich wenn sich das co2 in der atmosphäre sogar in sauerstoff
umwandeln ließ die idee
algen die viel co2 aushalten dadurch könnten dann auch pflanzen auf dem mars gedeihen doch leider ist die
photosynthese der pflanzen zu diesem zwecke nicht wirklich effektiv
Schätzungen zufolge würde es eine million jahre in anspruch nehmen das co2 das maß
In so viel sauerstoff zu verwandeln dass wir dort atmen können würmer und insekten
könnten schon deutlich früher auf dem mars leben als wir doch das große aber würde die so
entstandene mars atmosphäre überhaupt bestehen bleiben würde nicht wieder eine erosion durch den sonnen mit stattfinden diese
ganzen prozesse sind noch lange nicht ganz verstanden doch vermutlich würde die atmosphäre erstmal für eine zeit bestehenbleiben eine dauerhafte lösung
Allerdings wäre dieses terraforming des mars nicht das ganze zeigt uns einmal mehr
Dass wir bislang nicht wirklich eine alte diese zu unserer erde als lebensraum haben wieder ein grund mehr
Etwas besser auf sie aufzupassen um unseren planeten und somit auch uns noch lange
Zu erhalten wenn er als erstes neues zum thema mars besiedelung da ist ja einiges
Im gange und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollten dann endet meine telefonnummer hier
Bei
Whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr als erstes von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und zu brüsten habe ich noch ein
kleines goodie für euch einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum masters in der die pläne von allen masc
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran